we're living in an era where you're
right a part of it and say you're not
feeling that you're depressed take two
of these see what happens to you it's
the hero's Ark and this is the thing
this is why what I'm saying when people
say you don't know you don't know how it
feels to be depressed to say yes I do
the difference is how it's analyzed I
always argue this two ways as well when
depressed people come to me because one
of my most famous things people attack
me for is their little quote is they say
you said depression isn't real what
about the man who kills himself you
don't care about men's mental health
we've already discussed how I care more
about men's mental health than these
people pretend they do that's the first
thing say I didn't say depression isn't
real I said feeling depressed is real
but the idea that depression is going to
strike you in your mind and there's
nothing you can do about it I think that
is promoting helplessness amongst
depressed people and that's the reason
they kill themselves I don't think that
making people helpless in an unfortunate
situation is a great thing to do you
have to give people hope
and I explained that when you believe in
something you give it power so I tried
to say that when I felt at my lowest and
I achieved the most I've ever achieved
in my life the reason I was capable of
doing that is because I didn't believe
in the Paradigm of being a depressed
person